Avatar to the way of the water it was
beautiful you get lost in it like I
thought I was watching National
Geographic like I thought I was watching
like oh they're doing a like a
documentary on on this space world that
they found that's how beautiful it
looked that's how real it looked it was
really it was really spectacular and
fantastic and just go with an open mind
of like looking for escapism this was
the movie for that it is total escapism
and I gotta say it was beautiful it was
a beautiful story I I was with the story
you know I was like oh this is nice this
family struggle that's like trying to
raise your kids in a in a world where
you're trying to like be a father but
you're trying to protect them but at the
same time you're trying to make sure
they're strong and then I remember being
a kid and rebelling against my parents
and like I want to prove myself huh you
know there was loss there was uh uh
Triumph there was you know it was really
it was really beautiful I would go watch
it again but it is long y'all wow three
hours it's a three hour long movie I
give this movie 10 ten woo-woos
[Music]
so go see Avatar